and now film theory presents a dramatic
reading
of the comments from our last godzilla
vs kong theory
monkey monkey
monkey monkey this has been a dramatic
reading of the comments
good evening
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that bows to no one
but we'll do an extremely grateful
curtsy if you remember to make like a
titan and smash that subscribe button
and hey would you look at that
ring the bell ladies and gentlemen we
got one right we got one
really right our prediction theory for
godzilla vs kong
crushed it like predicting every beat of
the movie right on the money how's that
old saying go even a blind squirrel
finds a nut well i am buried and nuts
baby
um phrasing but you know what i'm not
done i'm not gonna rest on my yannis or
my laurels by just predicting the movie
that we got i want to go one step
further i want to predict the movie that
we
didn't get i.e i want to show you the
version of godzilla vs kong that we
didn't and probably will
never get to see i'm coming for you wb
scrounging around to assemble the
footage that you left behind on your
cutting room floor today we're using
everything from hollywood gossip and
production team interviews to narrative
themes and odd dangling threads left
behind in the final product to assemble
the godzilla vs kong movie that you
never saw
the film that they didn't want you to
see was it better
was it worse well stay tuned and let me
know down in the comments below if you
think that they made the right decision
so where is this theory actually coming
from well while watching godzilla vs
kong more than a few people
myself included noticed that it
sometimes felt like this thing was
shipped with a few parts missing oh sure
we have our essential story beats of
lizard monkey fight humans running away
lizard and monkey team up against evil
robot but between it all there were
plenty of lingering questions
questions like why aren't we following
up on most of the unresolved plot
threads from the previous movie
and where did the bad guys from the
previous movies go also this
guy i mean everything about this guy now
sure every movie shoots a lot more
footage than it uses and has scenes that
don't make the final cut that's been the
case like forever but when godzilla vs
kong director adam wingard says that
there's enough extra footage to do a
five hour version yeah i'm gonna sit up
and take notice after all they were
already in pre-production for godzilla
vs kong before they knew that the bigger
darker prequel king of the monsters was
a bit of a dud in terms of ticket sales
all of this and more begs the question
what was this movie before all the
studio notes production pauses and
pandemic delays now to be fair there is
technically a bit of actual plot in this
thing godzilla has gone
all city attacky again and this big tech
company called apex says they've figured
out a special weapon that can stop him
but they need a power source to do it
that power source is hidden somewhere in
the earth's hollow core to retrieve it
they need kong to lead the way because
of um
because of uh genetic memory and sam
something about salmon
spawning shut up it's a godzilla movie
on kong's team is a little girl named
gia who can talk to kong with sign
language
meanwhile eleven from stranger things
returns as her godzilla whisperer
character named madison apparently she's
the only person who has ever watched a
movie before ever
because she can tell that the big
obviously evil company is actually evil
causing godzilla's destructive behavior
with their anti-titan weapon the
creatively named
mechagodzilla mechagodzilla in true neon
genesis evangelion form
uses a neural interface to bridge a
human pilot with the uplinked mind of
the defeated alien king ghidorah from
the previous movie
this obviously goes awry when ghidorah's
consciousness wakes up and takes over
the giant robot
as predicted kong and godzilla have to
team up to bring him down and in the end
everyone gets there happily ever after
except for hong kong which lays utterly
decimated in the battle so the first
thing that should jump out to you while
listening to the short plot summary is
that both titans get their own cheering
section
team kong's gia is a skull island native
who communicates with her titan via a
crudely fashioned doll in sign language
compare that to team godzilla's madison
who used technology throughout both of
her movies to reach the giant lizard one
mission is funded with high-end super
science military tech the other is
running out of a sketchy van driven by a
conspiracy
podcaster they are clearly set up to be
opposite polarities which is
why it's weird when it gets to the
ending and you realize that this is the
first time the two teams have ever met
or even known of each other's existence
what was the narrative point in making
them
so noticeably similar just for them to
never interact well
that's where our mystery character comes
in see this guy the creepy apex henchman
chief technology officer who's always
following the main villain around with
the silent
i'm obviously more important than my not
talking would indicate stare
well in the movie as it stands he turns
out to be mechagodzilla's pilot
until the ghost of king ghidorah
immediately electrocutes his brain and
takes full control
kind of a pointless role right wrong
he's actually meant to be the son of dr
sir zawa the heroic scientist from the
first two godzilla movies
let them fight now don't feel bad if you
didn't catch this one they only say his
last name like
once the first time he's introduced and
his connection back to one of if not the
most important human character from the
previous films goes completely
unmentioned
not in dialogue not in reference nothing
it's also clear that this was never
meant to be a surprise reveal
considering in pre-movie interview
footage his character's full name is
just laid out there on the table
so in this one character we have
ourselves the son of the guy who was
obsessed with godzilla and even died to
bring the big lizard back to life in the
previous movie
and now this son of his is not only
working with the guys who want to
destroy godzilla he has literally
volunteered himself to become the brain
of the weapon designed to kill it
i mean there has got to be some kind of
revenge or
daddy issue stuff that's been left on
the cutting room floor here you don't
have to be a hollywood screenwriter to
see the whole
dad you missed my recital to go look for
godzilla
again let me hop into my megazord and
take out my childhood frustrations arc
totally taking shape with this character
especially when you consider that the
other main minion in this film is the
corporate villain's daughter real
daughter and his surrogate son
whole thing is like a family affair on
the villain's side but more relevantly
if that
had actually been ren shirozawa's
character arc in the film it would have
made him and mechagodzilla fit neatly
into the mirroring dynamic that the
other two titans have with their support
teams it also works thematically
all three of these characters are
dealing with loss by relating to their
titans in their own unique ways
gia lost both her family and island only
to find comfort with her titan
madison's mother was one of the bad guys
and her father is well-meaning but aloof
just like the sometimes good
sometimes bad but always elusive
godzilla and just like ren seeking
revenge on the dino that stole his
father
mechagodzilla or rather ghidorah's
severed head is
angry and craves revenge against the
thunder lizard this would also make
sense with some of the casting around
the movie
back in 2017 chinese actress zhang ji
was cast into the monster verse but her
actual role was kept somewhat mysterious
until the release of king of the
monsters where it was revealed that she
was actually playing
two separate characters twin sister
scientists working with the titan
studying organization monarch
this was a winking nod back to the
original mythology of these monsters
where a set of twin infant island
priestesses were traditionally
associated with the mothra mythology and
while she was supposed to be appearing
in the new godzilla vs kong none of our
scenes made the final cut
now considering that she was on dr
sirazawa's exploration team in the
earlier movie
and was there when he died the only
character it would make sense for her to
connect with would be
ren possibly explaining his decision to
join apex in order to avenge his father
so is that it a few extra scenes
fleshing out the backstory to one of the
random humans
all cut for time because let's be honest
no one cares about the human storylines
in these things i'm sorry about your
brother
you know gia's parents were killed on
the island it was a gift from my sarah
nobody care i think the cut content
around ren serizawa was also setting up
where the franchise would head to next
remember this movie was already well
into pre-production when king of the
monsters underperformed as such
it's likely that some of the cut
materials were meant to set up where the
monster verse would head
next after the big title bout and the
answer all
lies here i mean let's be honest here
one of the clunkier more
awkward parts of this movie is how both
ren sirozawa and ghidorah's head are
both needed to activate mechagodzilla i
mean in the final movie it basically
goes like this is dna
self-generating neural pathways capable
of intuitive learning
it had three heads this next was so long
they communicated telepathically
there's one here another one inside of
that that thing all right since this was
a bunch of scientific gobbledygook let
me try they needed the psychic powers of
ghidorah's skull to filter through a
human brain in order to pilot a giant
mech for
reasons it is long it is awkward and if
you pay attention to how many lines
about this thing get set in
adr it's probably not what the original
intention was
for those who don't know the letters adr
in filmmaking stand for automated
dialogue replacement
it's the process of re-recording
dialogue after filming to improve the
quality or make changes to the original
script now you can usually tell bad
or rushed adr dialogue in one of two
ways either the audio quality shifts
slightly
madani poor woman has tuberculosis or
the dialogue doesn't perfectly match the
character's lips
yes yes your opinion since matching the
audio up completely to the original
scene
is incredibly difficult and time
consuming many movies cover up adr
by not showing the actor while they're
speaking on camera a recent high-profile
example of this is with the disney plus
series falcon in the winter soldier
where an entire central plotline about a
global disease had to be cut because of
the current world situation and as a
result
most lines about the actual plot of the
series are said off-camera
i want the serum back or i will find you
notice how the mentions of the serum
happen without
anyone on screen it implies that those
lines had to be recorded
later and merged in whatever footage
that had already been shot
let's watch the lip sync okay now how
does this apply to godzilla vs kong well
notice how any and all lines about
ghidorah's skull or
the upgrade are spoken with ren off
camera and pay attention to the audio
quality which has slightly more reverb
and hollowness to it when he's the one
speaking
we have no idea how this energy source
will affect the makeup we're in the
goddamn chair it implies that there was
more to the plot than the skull
only serving as an energy source my
guess was that godor was eventually
meant to possess
ren shirozawa and if you think that
sounds insane remember that the final
plot of this thing that they expect us
to roll with is that the dead space
dragon demonically possessed a robot via
wi-fi
so really not that much further of a
stretch here's the thing
this one small change of ghedora
possessing ren one
makes everything a little bit clearer
two gives a reason for
a pilot having to be inside the suit
three makes sense considering they
already talk a lot about ghidorah's
psychic powers and four
it sets up a villain for the future
movies that's right after you've already
done the big battle royale with all the
famous monsters and then the big monkey
lizard fight there's nowhere else to go
except
mecca ghidorah yeah that is a thing at
one point better known from imported
godzilla toys than from films mecca
ghidorah was a cyborg
introduced in 1991's godzilla vs king
ghidorah
like a lot of the second wave or heisei
era godzilla films its broader plot was
a kaiju stuffed riff on popular
international blockbusters of the era in
this case the movie they were riffing on
believe it or not was the terminator
series i'll be back no joke in the main
story time travelers from the future
come to godzilla ravaged present-day
japan offering to help they do this by
going even further back in time to the
40s to prevent godzilla's mutation
but wait there's a twist these time
travelers are actually a multi-national
coalition of villains whose real agenda
is to prevent japan from becoming a
world economic superpower
they do this by leaving adorably
merchandisable baby gadoras to get
mutated one thing leads to another and
eventually the good guys turn the
remains of the defeated godora into a
human piloted cyborg adding to the
weirdness it was also supposed to be a
king kong movie
yeah the plan was to do a huge godzilla
event movie specifically time to the
30th anniversary of king kong vs
godzilla and since touhou figured
correctly that universal and the other
rights holders to kong would never let
them use the character for a reasonable
price they set the storyline up with all
the time travel and robotics to justify
using mecha kong but when their lawyers
figured that yeah the americans will
probably find a way to make that not
okay toho decided that ghidorah robot
would be a solid runner-up so my guess
is that the death of renshire zawa in
the pilot seat of the mech was actually
meant to be
a possession in the pilot seat of the
mech meant to keep the ongoing monster
villain of the series alive
waiting to strike again but in the
future the monster verse became unclear
all references to weirdly supernatural
stuff like that had to get cut including
any end credit scenes alluding to wren
still being alive and
under the control of the giant space
dragon and there you have it theorists
the secret plot to godzilla vs kong that
you'll never see
ren shirazawa looking to get revenge on
the lizard that killed his father
joins forces with apex to control the
monstrosity known as mechagodzilla when
ghidorah is too much for the suit to
handle he gets possessed which opens the
door to more mechanized dragon madness
in future installments would it have
added much to the final movie
probably not no one watches these things
for the humans but would it have made
the final product we got a bit more
cohesive yeah
probably and also because of those cuts
this movie
felt like a definitive end for the
characters no end credit scene no
nothing and yet it was very clearly a
hit in the box office meaning that
they're gonna want to make more
so the long story short friends don't be
surprised if the next film's trailer
opens with a peek inside the wreckage of
mechagodzilla only to have
ren's eyes pop open but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and it's springtime over here at
theorist hq and you know what that means
what's that leave my house to marvel in
the beauty and fertility brought forth
by the vernal equinox
you must be new here though now that you
mention it i have been trying to make
more of an effort to go up
sorry give me a second to go out sorry
to go outside
and given that it's springtime and
today's video is sponsored by our good
friends at bright sellers i am
officially declaring at the start of
white wine season that's
right baby no more living in fear of
being chided for drinking a riesling in
january and if you have no idea of what
i just said keep listening because i
think bright sellers might be perfect
for you
bright sellers is the monthly wine
subscription that uses a seven question
quiz to match
you to wines based on your tastes the
quiz is powered by an algorithm that
analyzes your taste profile to suggest
wines that you'd be guaranteed to like
they make it fast and easy to try wines
that are sourced from all over the world
i don't know about you but before i
started my wine education with bright
sellers i got super intimidated in the
wine section at the grocery store i mean
there are just
so many options and there's only so much
you can tell about a wine from just the
label on the bottle but with bright
cellars every bottle comes with these
handy cards explaining the wine's
origins flavor notes pairing suggestions
and more
over the months of me using bright
cellars they've given me the vocabulary
and knowledge i needed to feel
competent when it comes to all things
wine plus i can actually go to my bright
sellers account and rate the wines i
receive on a scale of one to five so
that the next round is even better
suited to my tastes so not only am i
learning about wine in general i'm
actually learning about the particular
profiles notes and flavors that i
specifically like for instance who knew
that buttered popcorn would be a flavor
that i look for in my wines
bright sellers did that's who bright
sellers has given the theorist community
an exclusive 50
off their first six bottle box plus a
bonus bottle if you use the link down in
the description right below this video
so take the quiz and get started on your
wine education today
that's 50 off your first six bottle box
plus a bonus bottle by using the link
down in the description below and i'll
see you all
next week